in welcoming Molly the loss I'm sorry
and speaking like a true so it was
reason my name is would be the stream
and my thing is of course for bb10 yet
could work as you know is a Barrett
stirring but as such the collection of
facts and events which were gathered
into a common an initial name in other
place meaning to be understood the name
was invented by ricotta raise themselves
before nope believes control and
according to Ramona a homogeneous
friends sometimes this was impossible on
the world was improbable record warmest
felt as a confrontation between to lash
rocks to move-- asked geopolitical
Croatians defined by the theoretical
project about the definition of
societies did they were democracy and
capitalism for enterprise versus what
would a democracy and socialism it was
also fat as a struggle for the
definition of humanity's future
according to the analysis of my model at
this time it was also an available
because it was a global conflict but not
anomalous because the acquisition of
territories was not a good post in
and set the current record starting
point is the end of a sermon world war
in 1945 conventionally is Giants
identify it stands with a form of a bell
in war in 1989 autocorrects of serotonin
in 1991 event if the intensity of the
conflict itself has already recovered
from the 1980s and what leads promised
my daughter about 40 years the position
of the contemporaries is complemented by
but of the Australians with a family
record well as well as stage of European
civil war over each of extremes which
begin in 1918 30 it was described as
search by journal editors at the time
who could not know what would come good
to be Daniel M is trying to compare it
with a penetrated Peloponnesian War
obvious in Greece maybe the pinnacles of
bra plus two selectors and previous
brother references a frugal protagonist
of the Cold War solar water as the
contradiction of two coalition's they
also have knowledge that this war was
linked to allow this to a cult
phenomenon further monitoring the most
important of which was different
decolonization this established the
petition was indeed a crucial issue the
problems identified
play if a rope or a magic player was
considered as a own manipulated by other
side are available at the bottom istic
player we did you use with you sighs
relativity or at the same time when what
else 2g village area the 16th century
dimensions free topologies our own world
amateur whore the shop won the division
which fitted is for climate free pass
today the stones river use values other
addictive qualities this corner as a war
phenomenon came within the scope of the
women and the distinctive distinctive
features of each mission of a war
according to local authority or pay
attack the korea to be situation since
military enemy is 57 spacing between the
lens the variance to civil wars at the
same time and so do support abilities
first one of course is remain civil war
you don't understand tins of CA Edward
right in front of others
working the lamps are going out for over
Europe we shall not see them late again
a long time and of course seen 19 f 40
40 40 site has remained some of the
violence in the world when chairman is
random Europe Western charity devastated
and the analyst position defined of
those ships virtue for two relations
moon explorations quickly it was we had
a front row home my broken we were
detecting clash of the Armed Forces over
to science indeed Europe became the only
geographical zone where the two rocks
we're facing each other river animals
European countries were brought from
empires and the main sticks of the convo
from a political on as well as a
strategic point of view yet the
repetition were two most conflicts did
not take place because of a
neutralization respect is cross in
Europe too much factors and country for
this neutralization neutralization the
first one is very clear amount which
made the mobilization of course of civil
Megan searchers ineffective at first
american preparing of atomic government
what is only one element of a balancer
process since it was only been righted
forties but in us as sufficient
quantities of nuclear arms which are the
capacity to destroy their planet but at
that time so they're two min or so at
such arms whose capacity to destroy was
increased with a switch to the iteration
by the student factor in this
feminization of a position / / hyerin
protein that the constitution of
military brass such as a fat rock group
was so packed and the beginning of the
50s the net definitive elements of a
birthmark in europe was constituted to
minute I systems with classics ours are
nuclear forces menacing each other in
the aeration of mutual assured
destruction madam and with their aim
answered permanent some type of tension
the situation was similar to a kind of
thought the desert of data way to work
but don't worry similary factors
complemented that determines mechanism
first White was a protagonist cushion
it's in the same agenda that
conservative visions of interest at this
paper Bay of every price during the
Civil War oh it's just war was to
preserve and facilitate its territorial
gains impossible overall the first
history basement of popular democracies
were indeed but as aggression by the
West that petrol a private coup but must
who I never remains northern ambition to
go away from the Soviet Union passive
itself has been in a difference a
position
at the same time the American strategist
never had the permission to destroy in
the process when production took shape
in 1957 the purpose was to contain the
Soviet expansion and to wait for a
moment when the Soviet system will
change and we look longer a bigger
fridge air again the night but at least
we're safe its line of action as a
defensive what other factors was the
evolution of international not low
synthesis what more during where
anti-god well there is no classic type
or were beginning with the declension of
world and ending with abyss determined
earlier have a conflict stemmed from the
decolonization which bin aber finished
not center and rush and no China Korea
Vietnam and which off hand and the
characteristic of civil wars with a
participation of fern fossils they're
aware of surah was made by witnesses to
apples of pain for ice police operations
police operations need to prepare a
fruit without questioning a date or
framework frightened born better ask
answer as a nineteen fifty fifty six as
a result the current world did not are
any territory or substance and the
sticks must interact internal represents
I try to act open the political process
of the countries involved economic aid
was another means to pray
ma successful example being the national
plan they were also correct action for
financing to propaganda intelligence
aggression the prevalence was to change
with pretty good ratings of an epidemic
mother's not change borders in Europe
apart from the excitation eternity in
fiber and Austria the division and two
blocks period with of course a question
more complex of yugoslavia in welcome
element collapse Alvarez mayor follow
like dominoes and it is precisely what
happened in 1989 if you can traverse
last stitch of very relaxing a one it
was also its exit it made any
improvement in Europe impossible in put
an end to Belgium vans in Europe we're
makin strategy meant to capture the
Soviet expansion it could in an economic
reconstruction the welfare state and the
consumer society the FSSA which we are
also used to show a lack of achievements
of a parasite we made success of
strategy
mr. Wesley protector Kevin Europeans
together which were connected turn with
the 1957 treaty of rome the six hundred
farmers as recently fought each other
and there was a willingness to never let
welcome between when they came to which
was edit an epidemic invention generally
and this vibes reverse of depolarization
europe a balanced web culture in favor
of this pressure as soon a 98 77 hi mama
no wonder her furniture abdicated for
Europe a few days later differences were
made to the notion of soft power and the
preferred pretends for Venus other funds
from us from a site where parents did
not become a key this lobbying morrison
consumer overnight it was record below
which were opened to become such the
medium in statistics takes the
dictionary miniature europe was
presented as the best developed part of
europe with military dictatorship such
as spain and sometimes twist
but she has no popular democracy under
Vejle the chair politics or 1945 took
the traditional return months of a
village and policy since the 18th
century first southwest Pacific
jerusha's were Soviet Union roosters
this intent the access to military or at
least its permanent settlement the great
Civil War the uverse lamented schism and
finally a rupture that will be happiness
of the Soviets in 1916 did not a love
letter to enjoy the presence of
popularity prophecies were in the
Mediterranean reversal part go forever
and relaxing in 1945 the Soviet Union
European the question of the streets
which led to a que to us for repair of
United States was government center were
fate near istanbul the situation wasn't
jealous him adapt to a pattern over us
130 years of a terminal iya when the
lady she was up to never demonstration
to stop a revolution progression because
one was in 1791 doing a Chekhov first I
Nevada Schmidt was sent to the streets
to brother Sir Richard provisions and
this plate speaking as you know the 66
plate and after
the 650 this plate is medicinal herbs /
British with Italian fed / 19th century
unlike the tread ensures a network of
home ports in the central western parts
of a vegetarian it is composed of pepper
and sea forces dispatch hundred other
American effects mysteries carries
nuclear armaments which is why it's
completely the devil responsibility of
United States this morning generally
station in the central vegetarian but it
is ready to intervene in the western
Mediterranean I went towards the back
ends got to Ravenna based a web page
type of case is a diplomatic estimate it
is a show frost we need to be used about
the other from the intelligence in the
ballon energy 50-acre during villa bella
civil war and against libya the 650 that
participated in any combat operation
during the control the combination of a
six feet under european markets and
through the supremacy of the West in the
Mediterranean the Soviet fibers garage
brothers became an Apache tree were only
from the mid-60s and it was dissolved in
make you work with us western star chick
planning at the time when her radar here
was two stages of the total force
sentence of dvorn there could be no
effective bag against an attacker buried
army as far as the Atlantic look at the
disappearance went took have a pattern
of a paired from 1942 1944 put a note in
Europe would be left to enemy and they
seized as well as benefits would prevent
him from going very high so we the West
prepare the super boardwalk not refer
jerk a wasn't good to the continuity
with Soviet bloc where'd army would be
able too much as far as us which was
most important British military was this
was where the final battle with Nick
place thanks to a progressive Western
Maryland the piece of a fictional battle
was police ladies shipped normal Lucy
nine and that the Palestine and after
Sarah doctors after to the cave jordan
80 the ridge was pretty much at work was
no hands
so the new stick was were not happy a
Turkish mothers would be the better fits
in the geographic proximity of an idea
going from the militant to Pakistan
which was constricted by the bad leg
part of nineteen fifty 50 Centrum in any
case the strategic imperatives change
general ibrahim process of delay the use
of nuclear forces so as to give politics
a chance to overlook a strong lamar pad
and oil the american production when the
Middle Eastern oil into one of the
crucial elements of independent accrue
destruction of Europe in the midterm or
it was supposed to live his core as the
main source of energy at the end of the
forties in socially she was to get
report of the graph to come to the
shores of the Mediterranean we are
pipelines and it wasn't her time their
time were British tasting the British
imperial system divided in 20 or so
years a city security of it appeared
were ways of communication principles at
least the earth planted consent of the
countries concerned seen from Moscow the
soft roar of the region seemed to women
control by a direct or anti domination
course whereas for military issue at
stake was to succeed in keeping this
demolition at risk of creating the
disjunction between the Europeans the
u.s. so stunning policy was interested
in Parisian holidays so as to weaken the
Western strategic system we wish which
was festive awesome and sacrament
attempt that's why the Soviets book a
super to the Kurds in Iraq of bosnian
and and and the creation of the State of
Israel which did to hurt on a blow to be
British control over their guests never
less intense than in death so sorry
policy women perceive the slimming
version of the players with clear of
city man cell free from European
domination and let's work less of a
Palestine warm hues with an even more
again between weekend and it's our
allies when she did not support during
the conflict and after the war or the
attempts to integrate the countries
paste into the military system which
have to be rated x / soviet rate hike
the Harlem atticus you were swept the
military base ask us which were banished
ended up attending because it's must of
strategic values is reliability to a
nuclear attack and the permanent
hostility of Egypt
North Africa in Africa the struggle for
independence of the two protectorates of
Morocco Tunisia was essentially domestic
courier labour French were compared to
yield for failure general installation
we handed up accepting the passive mode
of another day Dakota colonization we
were almost completed by 1955 this lat
insight into the situation of the new
dependence these two met in good
relations who resisted nezam while they
completed their endeavor by conquest or
where countries actually had one start
in 1953-54 was essentially led by the
italian arabs himself supported in
different ways by the power of an Arab
countries the supportive associate his
blood was very limited it was mainly
political unli refresh am a foot it was
ready to work against international
communism and trying to pursue their
American put up a status fight was akin
Traverse Virginia the u.s. refused to
agree with both of you why banded
friends carefully and so it as the sick
man of Europe they made it clear but
we're ready to put it with a dependent
on China it sanitary this was a one of
the Sorcerer's attend Americanism for
the
shrug the turning point is 1955 when the
strategy of studying successors umberto
Vanessa and achieved converge with a
common opponent without that part and
anything factor the question of almond
the end of the Western monopoly was fed
as a measure with Tariq lightly Arabs
who have been compared to bridge the gap
between the military forces on both of
his trial so it's men it leads to higher
prices and the Egyptian revolution
appear has been enabled we must work
compared to the wisdom interest from the
French suggested back in a Shia from
British rock 11 are near missed and
forever against incident at NASA was
trying to fool them by giving them fake
equal did an arbitrary piece was from a
god Alpha Gamma mega haul has really
difficult edge mysterious prices and we
were on Dagobah 56 broke out but I said
our administration was strategic
perception as debating the fact that
researcher before vote for Roma that
stick since it is splitting off from
Europe and then try to project out the
nationalism by using contigo medicine as
a nice groups or protest and we have a
pragmatic antique antagonism
you're a key evolution put an end to get
a settlement operation of another NJ on
the back part but we added Nestor that
it did not want to exchange one kind of
domination father any rapprochement we
facility noon was occupied I had a
general deficient against commenced
European imperialism had been summarized
by the business of military bases went a
given its privilege to the Soviets
what's out of edition so the converse a
great game with covert action and could
it our top in which aims finishing local
political forces whenever they were
documents show but to western province
were involved in many operation on
Spanish it is enraged by the Western
powers were involved with the shampoos
on 1949 and the Civil attempts to
describe in CA gallant in 1958 an actor
in Iraq during the chasm which in the
French and the British at the difficult
times deliberateness heir apparent well
as
the Arab progressive leaders with action
of the same time against where a
reaction associated with compile is
event Zionism in the rewards Jordan and
Saudi Arabia when a second or so let
their own sacred rules against guessing
the rites sometimes with Americans and
then against the Syrian and directly
basis Bridget contrary to the legends of
the Cold War the Soviet children are
listed in the background of certain
parties apart from the supergravity to
be personal destiny we are family
started did you receive general
direction from the saloon but except in
Iraq this is to be an important pages
the believer stage as facility new
preferable relation we work on tricity
from the interest of the Communist Party
the Eastern Bloc this is silly women in
an interstate relationship with a
progressive our country's intelligence
services of both parties at the
declarative were nothing more the
foundation of a solid policy where there
are supplies the trading of unitary and
technical areas and economic ad serving
based the deepsmen of socialism it was a
policy of influence not the direct
control this is also true of a
Palestinian world month halfback 1967
which pseudo volatile political kind of
confirmation from Moscow we are
operating persistent provided the
necessary sources of funding
the Soviet did not organized the events
where many follow him they were not able
to act otherwise because ferrara
perfeito italian widgets did not allow
event to encroach on web in general 780
it was partly evident when her freshman
idiot never sweated was created in the
middle of the 16th the progressive
argued as many SS valero facilities a
newsmen as meant to patricia on both
Moscow on woteba the Soviet squadron
lighten American fit was a demonstration
of force an element of nuclear
deterrence concept of powers where they
were celebrities he appeared to be a
conservative one as soon 1957 win the
shipping of plan this policy suggested a
kind of division into civil space of
attributes we were the US it's so
miscalculation protiviti to do more of a
nineteen sixties develop the ultimate
purpose of a soviet union was to achieve
abyss implement of the artist I conflict
from did a very establishment of the
borders of reforms own 1967 and which we
rented an affluence important too much
over United States in fact the survey
the mission was to restore a kind of
content between the great progress
similar to mention which had a sister
before the First World War transfer
proposed was first edition of the
concept of nation on certain European
concept of a 19th century France
endeavour free Frederick make no mistake
about this game unconscious leads to
switch time to it the Soviets attitude
toward the nearest was similar to but
adapted with India it was a policy of
insurance or partnership majority by
geographical jeopardy quality Asian
Venice Egypt was the painful from Otto
Soviet decision makers we were first to
recognize the dependence are they under
our partners during the World Court one
apparent of course of action of a super-
geographies was to try to suppress the
military bases of the current your
parent if ecology and receive a closure
of military bases in the southern shores
of Mediterranean must was needed a
blissful in 1970 and has no Soviet novel
bus in Arab countries only facilities
remind discourse of related countries
whereas Nunnally meant until Pietism
which is not prevent managed from having
a professor a while I'll recover our
children's opportunism that some
creators led us to create a kind of
competition between connects the circlet
positive neutralism development and i
was often consider as a Jew the referral
our policies for a military an countries
and as I the European but it can come
chase sutra privileged relation with
regard countries for example France as
Alaska policy after a giant world of 52
cooperation meant to strengthen the
community of French speaking peoples of
God funny if any agrees we're also very
present in the proposal made to the
countries of the social because
sometimes our policies but not only
pressure operation Spanish our policy
italia our position apart from the
commercial objective less tradition when
a giant lee they are rich the statue of
the coal producer is our policy at the
ambition to reduce the dependence on the
beliefs of countries of the soviet union
and to strengthen the countries which
way
as moderate so wish things begin to
change in this seventies first factor
was they began in our high rent Iran
destroyed but the development society
mother of development to introduce new
finishes the equites we change the
system of dependencies and the whole
cover stroke of the 1980s created the
real depth crisis in fact the main deck
team under front of her from people game
and was saluting him Antonovich show
where was lodged itself in the white
unification project the crucial moment
was when trial of grace and Orthodox
welcome country may join the European
culture on labor 19th century Spain and
Portugal 40 1986 the post-cold war many
tangible it will start to image in the
80s with fundamental imbalance of poor
relations very political project
increasingly match that your particular
plans of Arabia but over Atlanta
that's to say its military definition
collision for first request for Western
strategist the old world religion was
revealed a buried his owner of the
Atlantic events European communism was
mostly a military term in exam which
asserted moments were even able to at
least participate in power in France of
Italy or Spain and Portugal remedy
generation was whichever flickered
transition toward referred war which
making the Chilton bat afraid of the
corner the Rev Ernest the solidity
military system of the Atlantic islands
Cooper perfect robot or six big big
possible korean defense of a la frog as
far as taking this is no remedy jam in
there a Catholic cobra venom table
process of European Constitution Soviet
Union for Soviet Union the mid internet
was a place where it would be bypassed
relevant II meant to contain expansion
the interests of studies successful
match also a definition nationalist
since for attempted to destroy the
business strategy of a social reading of
materialism but the radicular lies
countries did not want to swap one kind
of definition for unaware and took
advantage of the balance of power system
great opportunity scary so in fact
record water in the media can reproduce
the 19th century game between relief or
worse we call it the Eastern mission we
never sent any complicated the context
of our history conflict under question
of palestine because of the fact that
history was made an asset into a Western
defense cenar countries begin realized
over Soviet Union and develop affordable
players from the fundamental elements of
discretion until the end of a cold world
there was no for 10 times between
the big bombers and the best process
we're married is not a mere battery
between the two cars so-called well as a
part of history of amid Italian perfect
record war lasted only 40 years it
blends to belong a span of a story on
the military which first mystery removal
Worf it's on the on both of his parents
the bus forever for which sometimes came
from further outside remedy Tanya simple
intensity hey when the British fleet
came in the Mediterranean for some first
outsider flesh in the negative 18
century where is your faith and so on
beginning when I
American fit in the middle Kenya the
colonization will open the game between
the big pores which stemmed from the
globalization of appts competed at the
end of an 18th century record world and
the specific embarked on the kitchen
device type the letter started much
before it and we've gotten one after